A&E's reality hit Storage Wars revolves around
the unknown, the bizarre, and the surprising,
all of which lay safely ensconced within abandoned
lockers.
Despite the plethora of oddball items, there
are certain discoveries that were bound to
rise to the surface as exceptionally noteworthy.
Barry Weiss, who is known as "The Collector,"
may not be the most successful character on
the show, but he certainly makes up for it
with his entertaining commentary, and hilariously
questionable bidding decisions.
"This has become personal.
This has become personal…$3,000."
All of this was on full display when Weiss
arrived late to an auction and quickly snapped
up what appeared to be a worthless locker
for an inflated $1,525.
But Weiss' seemingly harebrained mistake turned
out to be quite on purpose.
"You can only see somebody's mouth that's
open with teeth, and that's all you can see.
But I want it."
The Collector had spotted an interesting statue
in the back, and his suspicions were quickly
confirmed.
"This piece, got to be a one of a kind."
The statue had real dentures and glass eyes,
and its head had been hollowed out to house
its own little scene.
"There's pictures on the wall, there's a table
with a lamp, there's the moon out the window…"
"It's incredible!"
"... and there's this little troll."
The $6,000 appraisal that Weiss received wasn't
enough to tempt his offbeat tastes, and the
Collector chose to keep it for his own private
collection.
"Buddy, I'll see ya later."
"Take care."
Elvis Presley was the King of Rock n' Roll,
and there's no doubt that anything authentically
relating to his life and death is going to
carry some inherent value.
But it was Storage Wars' resident bad boy,
David Hester, that walked away with the Presley
motherload in Season One.
"My curiosity is up because somebody has these
newspapers wrapped and banded.
So I'm thinkin it's some type of collectible."
Hester managed to score a locker filled with
thousands of newspapers featuring Elvis on
the front page.
But it was the publication date that really
mattered here.
The vast collection of periodicals were all
dated August 16, 1977, the day Elvis died.
"This is something that is just gonna add
up to hundreds of dollars, or thousands of
dollars, or even tens of thousands of dollars
I think."
With such a large quantity of highly-valued
newspapers, Hester knew he had a fortune on
his hands, as proved to be the case when the
vault of rock and roll treasures was valued
at a whopping $90,000.
While Storage Wars and its spin-offs bring
treasure seekers to a wide variety of locales,
they've yet to venture into the deserts of
Asia.
Thus, one can imagine the surprise when the
ever-eccentric Mary Padian found a pair of
camel saddles in a locker during the show's
eighth season.
"These are so cool.
I just gotta figure out what the heck they
are, so I know where to take 'em."
The antiques became even more interesting
when she took them to be evaluated by a camel
owner.
Apart from being worth a pretty penny, the
rare valuables turned out to be specifically
made for shaggy, two-humped Bactrian camels.
This species of camel is native to the rocky
deserts of Central and East Asia, and are
among the only truly wild camels still in
existence.
"3,000?
That's double.
Double hump, I'm pumped."
The Storage Wars crew has seen a lot, but
they weren't prepared to encounter the occult.
At least, that seems to be the case judging
from Brandi Passante's face after she bought
a $900 locker midway through Season 5 that
contained some voodoo paraphernalia.
"I don't know what this spooky s--- is, but
I'm not touchin' it."
As Brandi and her team dug their way down
through the initial layers of worthless crap,
they were surprised to find a small skull
and antlers that immediately spooked them
out.
"This feels like some bad juju voodoo."
The supernatural concerns continued to mount
as the voodoo collection was further unveiled.
From trinkets and statues to chicken bones
and beaks, the witch doctor's stash was about
as unsettling as it gets.
"Maybe this is what the chief holds when he
sacrifices a virgin?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.